Did you know cats would go blind without the amino acid taurine,...
...an ingredient in many energy drinks?
Did you know many cats are actually lactose intolerant?
Did you know the doggy door was originally created for cats...
...and was invented by Sir Isaac Newton?
Did you know the largest house cat has record weight of over 46 pounds?
His name is Himmy and he's from Australia.
Did you know cats perceive their owners as other cats?
Giant oaf-like cats.
Did you know the richest cat in the world was left 24.7 million dollars by its owner?
Did you know house cats can run up to 30 miles per hour?
Did you know there are cat cafes in Japan and Korea...
...where you can drink coffee and hang out with cats?
Did you know there are cats that have survived falls from over 32 stories onto concrete?
Did you know in the 60s, the CIA spent 20 million dollars training cats as spies?
The first one in the field got hit by a taxi.